here to present the award for best
achievement in makeup are two women
whose own natural beauty could render
that particular category obsolete from
the Cotton Club
miss Lynette Mackey and from a woman in
red Miss Kelly LeBrock
the makeup artist has been an integral
part of the movie since the beginning
influenced by stage techniques early
film actors looked as though they'd been
made up in a bakery yes and as it
happened with each of the movie making
crafts makeup has become more and more
advanced and more and more an art in
itself from the 18th century foreign to
the 21st the work of this year's
nominees covered a span of some 400
years in Amadeus nominees Paul LeBlanc
created makeup off entik - the period
from theatrical phases of the masquerade
ball - depicting the effects of time on
Mozart's nemesis antonio salieri in
greystoke the legend of tarzan lord of
the apes.the knees rick baker and paul
Engelen created makeup for both man and
beast in 2010 Michael Westmore applied
his artistry to the aging process and
brought a chilling realism to the face
back to Keir Dullea and the winners
professed achievement in makeup are Paul
LeBlanc and dick Smith from honor death
I've been a makeup artist for 40 years
years full of excitement and happiness
many friends and this moment is just the
greatest of that time I'm very grateful
for it and especially to Murray Abraham
whose genius brought my old Salieri
makeup to such glorious life Paul and I
are especially honored because we know
how extraordinary the creations of Rick
Baker and Mike Westmore were and we're
proud to be their colleagues Paul did
all the other makeups besides the
Salieri one and please say yours thank
you very much I just want to say thank
you to Tom Sternberg for introducing me
to Saul Sanz who introduced me to Manasa
Foreman who introduced me to host gang
Amadeus Mozart thank you
the best achievement and sound the
nominees are mark Berger Tom Scott Todd
buckle height and Chris Newman for
Amadeus
it sounded good Villa Barney Steve Marlo
Kevin O'Connell and Nelson stole for
dune Graham we hearthstone Nicholas let
me say da Michael a Carter and John
Michell for a Passage to India
Richard Portman and David Ronnie for the
river
Michael J Kohut Aaron Rowand carlos de
la Rios and Jean s kanima safor 2010 may
we hear the sound of the envelope
tearing good the winners are mark Berger
Thomas
thanks to Saul Zaentz ambulance foreman
for the opportunity to work on Amadeus
and to my wife Susan Wayne graph Matthew
and Anya thanks to our San Francisco
sound editors Roy Siegel Alice Caldwell
and Cody Keith thanks to John Strauss
was wonderfully creative work on this
film made might work on it quite
pleasurable also mark adler for the
great tracks and Neville Marriner for
some wonderful readings of the music and
finally Wolfgang for writing it down
Kenny Weston Neil foul and Bob Gaul and
Peter and hope Newman all the people in
Czechoslovakia with profound gratitude
thank you